[Music]
she's sleeping
she needs to rest
it's like i can feel you through this
[Music]
door
[Music]
hey
do you remember when we first met
and you're yelling at me in spanish
i have no recollection of that i blame
lester's handwriting
what said 31 all right it is 37
and it came pounding on your door like a
jackass
do you ever wonder what would have
happened if you knocked on some other
girl's door
i knock on 100 a day
i've never met anyone like you
merely gladluster messed up that actress
yeah me too
[Music]
good morning miss garcia good morning
sunshine
i miss you i can
must stay
tensions indoors as we enter the 213th
week of lockdown grim new reality
emerges
23 has mutated beginning thermal scan
thermal scan normally a horrifying new
development new data confirms
all infected americans are being forced
into quarantine camps
[Music]
department of sanitation sarah talk to
me i think my neighbor has a fever it'll
be so much easier if you just open the
door
mrs grant you have visitors
[Music]
anomaly detected armed guards will be
arriving in four to six
hours you must not attempt to leave your
home or you will be shot on site
to you i know you're in there
you're coming i have to let you go
no no no no say goodbye to me
sometimes we have to do things we don't
want
to survive i'm trying to save the one
person left in my life
that matters to me
i can't help you what you're talking
about is illegal
come here
[Music]
and remember stay safe save and sanitize
[Music]
foreign